SPEAKER 1: All right.
Welcome, everyone.
Thanks for joining during
your lunch break and over VC.
I'm really excited to
introduce Myra Strober.
She's a Stanford
professor and author
who's here to share some
really great tips on how
to juggle your work
life and your home life.
I'm going to jump
right in, because we're
a few minutes behind.
And she's going to read an
excerpt from one of her books
and go over some slides and then
answer any questions that you
may have.
So Myra is a labor economist
and the professor emerita
at the School of Education
at Stanford University.
She's also the
professor of economics
at the Graduate
School of Business
at Stanford University.
Her research and consulting
focus on gender issues
at the workplace
and work and family.
She is the author
of numerous articles
on occupational
segregation, women
in the professions
and management,
the economics of child
care, feminist economics,
and the teaching of economics.
She was the founding director
of the Michelle R. Klayman
Institute for Gender
Research at Stanford,
and she was also the first
chair of the National Council
for Research on Women, a
consortium of US centers
for research on women which
today has more than 100 member
centers.
Over the years,
Myra has consulted
with several corporations
on improved utilization
of women in management
and on work family issues.
She has also been
an expert witness
in cases involving
the valuation of work
in the home, sex discrimination,
and sexual harassment.
So with that, I'll
have you take it away.
MYRA STROBER: Thank you.
Hello, everyone.
I'm going to start by
reading from my memoir, which
was published
recently by MIT Press,
and it's called
"Sharing the Work."
So I'm going to read from the
very beginning of the memoir.
Then I'll talk a little
bit about how partners
can balance family and careers.
And then we'll take questions.
You'll be able to tell in just
a minute when this takes place.
"It's because you
live in Palo Alto,
the chairman of Berkeley's
economics department tells me.
I can't have a regular job here
because I live in Palo Alto?
He nods.
Chairman [? Brake ?] is tall
with football player shoulders
and although I'm tall, too, his
massive frame towers over me.
He's a big shot in one of the
most prestigious economics
departments in the country.
I'm the assistant
professor wannabe.
If this meeting
doesn't go well, he
could decide not to
hire me for next year.
Under my jacket
rivulets of perspiration
are making their way down
my dress-for-success blouse.
You have to live in Berkeley
to be on your tenure track?
Again, he nods.
I'm baffled.
I never knew that.
My husband Sam is a medical
resident at Stanford
and works incredibly long hours.
Often he goes back to
his lab late at night
to check on his experiments.
We have to live in Palo Alto.
OK, I say softly,
getting up to leave.
Thanks very much.
When I get to my office,
my hands are shaking.
I can hardly insert
my key into the lock.
I feel drained, disoriented.
Did I take something out of my
freezer for tonight's dinner?
Lamb chops?
Hamburger?
I dial home but Margie, my
babysitter, doesn't pick up.
She's probably taken
the kids out somewhere.
I leave my office and
walk across Sproul Plaza--
surprisingly quiet after
all the years of student
demonstrations.
It's 1970 and the Vietnam War
is beginning to wind down.
I slide into my
full-sized blue Chevy
with a trunk large
enough to hold
both a stroller and a
carriage and review my meeting
with [? Brake. ?] I spend a lot
of time in Big Blue these days.
It's about an hour between
Palo Alto and Berkeley
in the morning and longer
in the late afternoon,
and I do the commute
three days a week.
Gradually crawling in
stop-and-go traffic
toward the Bay
Bridge, the absurdity
of [? Brake's ?]
answer registers.
My first response is to cry.
I grope around in my purse,
pull out some tissue,
and dab at my eyes.
But now the road is blurry.
I switch my thoughts
to my children.
Mommy, Mommy-- Jason,
my three-year-old,
will scream with delight when
he hears my key in the lock.
And Liz, 11 months,
will follow his lead.
She'll speed across
the living room
on all fours, tug on my
leg, and make joyful noises.
Suddenly the traffic
starts to move.
I can never tell why
the snarls dissolve,
but I'm always grateful.
As I drive at normal
speed, my thoughts
turn back to [? Brake. ?] But
this time instead of tears,
I'm aware of growing
anger-- at myself.
What's wrong with you,
I scream inside my head.
You let him intimidate you.
Let him make you mute.
You're a smart woman and you
let him make you look stupid.
Faculty don't have
to live in Berkeley
to be on the tenure track.
He fed you pure bull
and you bought it.
You want to know why you
can't have a tenure track
job at Berkeley?
Look at what's real.
There are no women except
Margaret in the whole economics
department faculty.
And although she's been
there for more than 20 years,
she's still a lecturer.
Wake up.
The difference
between a lecturer
and an assistant
professor is monumental.
Assistant professors
have a regular job
with an opportunity for
promotion and lifetime tenure.
Lecturers, on the other hand,
are on a road to nowhere.
They're appointed
from year to year
generally only a few months
before their teaching
is to begin and have
no chance of advancing.
I've worked too hard
for too many years
to be content with
second class citizenship.
I intend to get the
real deal at Berkeley.
When I finally get onto the
Bay Bridge, my anger changes.
Now I'm furious
with [? Brake. ?]
How dare he tell me I
have to live in Berkeley?
The radio is tuned
to a talk station,
and I register Joe Carcione,
the popular Green Grocer,
instructing the whole Bay
Area about choosing pumpkins.
Ah, Halloween is coming.
Maybe I should revisit
[? Brake's ?] office
in costume.
Witch?
Skeleton?
Big Bird?
Surely, some costume
could shake him out of his
we all have to live
in Berkeley routine.
With my sheath skirt and
matching man-tailored jacket,
I'm wearing stockings
and high heels.
The stockings feel
sticky and the shoes
pinch every time I accelerate.
How I would love to
kick off those shoes.
Whoever invented
high heels definitely
didn't have driving in mind.
I'm getting angrier by the
second-- at the traffic which
has snarled again, at my
gluey stockings and too tight
high heels, and
at my own naivete.
But most of all, I'm
angry at [? Brake. ?]
Slowly I begin to understand
what people mean when they say
their anger makes them see
red, because a swelling
fury-- a deep scarlet
anger-- now floods the car.
The steel frame and glass
windows can't contain it,
and it bursts onto the road
like a flaming oil slick--
a torrent sliding over
the bridge's girders
and thundering across the bay.
As the lights of
San Francisco begin
to flicker against the darkening
sky, I feel a flicker of light
within myself.
I become a feminist
on the Bay Bridge."
So the follow up to that story
is the morning afterwards,
I called [? Brake's ?]
office again
and asked for
another appointment.
And his secretary told
me he was very busy.
It would be several weeks
before he could see me.
So I had a second meeting
several weeks later,
and I asked him the
same question again.
And he asked me if I
wanted him to be frank,
and I said, yes, I did.
And basically he
told me that they
knew that I had both a
three-year-old and an infant
and that they didn't know what
was going to happen to me.
I said, happen to me?
What do you think is
going to happen to me?
If you give me a
position, in six years
I'll come up for
tenure and promotion,
and we'll all see
what happens to me.
He said, no.
He said, I could never sell
that to the department.
Well, in the mean
time-- having nothing
to do with me-- the
women faculty at Berkeley
filed a complaint with
the Labor Department
under a new executive order.
And investigators from the Labor
Department came to Berkeley.
And I thought to
myself, you're going
to have to sell that
to the department.
And I was right.
Because after two years, I got
an assistant professor offer
from Berkeley.
And if anybody ever tells
you that the law doesn't make
a difference, argue with them.
I also got an assistant
professor offer
from the Stanford
Business School.
Because although
Stanford had not
had a complaint
filed against them,
they were nervous that
there might be one.
And so in 1972, I was hired as
the first woman at the business
school.
The first woman at the
law school was hired.
The first woman in engineering
was hired, and on and on.
So I wound up teaching at
Stanford and not at Berkeley.
And I have had as one of my
fields of study all that time
how partners can balance
family and careers.
Because as you see, my
experience at Berkeley
was that they didn't believe
that I could possibly
balance a career at
Berkeley or presumably
anywhere else and also
have young children.
So what I want to do now is
talk about the main issues
that I see for people who do
want to balance two careers
and a family-- two demanding
careers and a family.
So let's take a look
at these slides.
You can't have it all.
As an economist,
I'm always perplexed
when people ask me the
question, can you have it all?
Economists are into trade-offs.
Nobody can have it all.
Something has to be traded off.
So you can have two demanding
careers and a family,
but something has to give.
Maybe it's no longer cooking
five gourmet meals a week
or playing tennis or
exercising regularly
or seeing your
friends as frequently.
But something is going
to have to change.
However, if two
people are committed
to two careers
and a family, it's
possible to achieve all
of that if they understand
what they have to give
up in order to do that
and if they're fully
committed to two careers.
What does it mean to be fully
committed to two careers?
It means that each
spouse has to--
or partner-- has to be committed
not only to their own career
but to the other career as well.
That's not easy.
And there are challenges
all along the way.
The most important career
decision you're going to make
is not really a career decision.
It's about who you're going
to marry or partner with.
And if you're already married
and things are not working out,
well, make sure you have
a conversation about this.
Make sure you
understand what it's
about to be committed
to two careers.
The first challenge is
where are we going to live
and where are we going to work?
And the answer to
these questions
are different for each
couple, because the specifics
are different.
So, for example, if one
partner is much more mobile
than the other
partner, then that
suggests that the couple should
locate where the person who
needs more mobility is.
Should we take turns
advancing our career?
Should we move here in the
first instance for one career
and then five years later
move for another career move?
Sometimes that works out well.
Sometimes it doesn't.
Sometimes if you keep switching
careers and nobody has
priority, then you wind
up with two careers
that aren't working well.
So you have to really
think about these issues.
They're tough.
Should we choose only locations
where both people can flourish?
Usually that works well.
And usually that means
a fairly large area.
So you know the Bay Area, Los
Angeles, New York, Chicago,
Atlanta-- places where
both members of a couple
can find jobs and move up.
Should we have a
commuter marriage?
That's tough.
The literature seems to suggest
that a commuter marriage works
for a while if
it's time limited--
if both people know that it's
not going to last forever.
And, of course, if there
are children involved,
then a commuter marriage
is really tough.
How about dividing housework
and home management?
Well, you may be
able to outsource
a good deal of housework.
But unless you are extremely
rich, you and your partner
will be managing your home.
How long will you divide
the management work?
People often forget about
the management function.
You know, they decide
who's going to cook
and who's going to clean up.
But they forget,
you know, somebody
has to be involved in who's
going to call the plumber.
But somebody has to know that
a plumber has to be called.
OK?
Somebody has to
know that you have
to sign up the kids for camp
before all the slots are
filled.
Those are all
management functions.
Are you going to be co-CEOs?
Or are you going to
divide up the function?
If you're going to
be co-CEOs, then you
have to have a lot
of communication,
as is always the
case when there's
more than one CEO involved.
Deciding when and
if to have a child.
Well, people always
ask me, when is
the best time to have a child?
The answer is that it's
always the best time
and it's always the worst time.
If you want a child,
it's the best time
whenever you have a child.
But a child is likely to slow
your career to some degree.
And if both members of the
couple are sharing childcare,
then it may slow both careers.
So, again, this is
a tough decision.
How are you going to
care for your children?
Well, leaving the
workforce-- one member
of the couple leaving the
workforce-- is one possibility.
And more and more dads
are leaving the workforce.
But that is a very
costly decision.
The person who
leaves the workforce
generally loses a good
deal of his or her network,
unless they make a
really conscious effort
to maintain that network.
Often their skills depreciate,
unless-- again-- they
make a very conscious effort
to keep those skills going.
And the literature shows
that when you come back--
when women come back-- there's
not enough men coming back
from childcare to study it yet.
But when women come
back, their earnings
are permanently lower
by as much as 20%.
Now this could be because
of the jobs they choose,
or because their new
bosses don't see them
as good material for promotion
because they've taken time out.
But in any case, the
combination of factors
leads to an earnings decrement.
Also people lose insurance
in case of divorce.
Because if you have to come
back to the workforce in case
of divorce, and you haven't
been in the workforce
for a long time, you're going
to have a lot of trouble
getting back in.
Part-time work is another
potential solution.
But often it's not a
very good solution.
It can be the worst
of all worlds,
because often employers don't
pay per hour what you would
get if you had a full time job.
Benefits are often lower.
Often employers
don't see people who
work part time as good
candidates for promotion.
And the other problem
that people tell me
about all the time is
that even though they've
negotiated a part-time schedule,
they wind up working full time.
So now it is the
worst of both worlds.
Because you are
working full time,
but you only have
a part time salary.
So where part time
seems to work best
is when you've already
been a full-time person
and you negotiate for part
time in a limited way.
So you say, you know, I'm
coming back from having a child.
And I want to work part time
for the next six months.
Can we work that out?
So that seems to be a
good solution there.
Inform yourselves about
childcare options early,
like when you know you're
going to have a child.
Because it's often difficult
to find good quality childcare.
And we know that good
quality childcare
is beneficial to children,
but not all childcare
is good quality.
And inform yourselves about
what to look for in terms
of the quality of childcare.
Now people always talk about
balancing work and family,
but that could be not
the ideal metaphor.
Because if you think of
balance as, you know,
the scales of justice with
equality, for most people
work and family is not equal.
For some work is higher.
For some family is higher.
But it doesn't mean that
the balance has to be equal.
I think the better notion
is the jar of life.
So figure out what things
in your life are the rocks.
What are the things that
really should go into that jar?
And put those things in first.
So after the jar is
filled with rocks,
then the pebbles
can all-- pebbles
and the sand can all
fill in around the rocks.
But you know that you've fit
in the most important stuff.
And I think in
striving for balance,
it's probably
fruitless to imagine
that your work
and family life is
going to be in balance
every day, every week,
maybe not even every month.
But what's important is that
you both continually work
to move back into what you
decide is the right balance.
And I like to think about
a band of acceptability.
OK?
So my work family is in
balance within this band.
And if I'm out here or
my family is out here,
then we agree that
we've got to get back
into our band of acceptability.
We've got to change
some things to get back.
So I like that notion
of work family balance
rather than the
scales of equality.
And finally, let me just say
that work family balance is not
just about you and your family.
Many of you are or
will be in a position
to help other people to
balance their work and family.
And when you make decisions
with your employees-- people who
report to you--
about how they're
going to be able to
balance work and family,
think about the
power that you have
to make their life more livable.
And also think about how we can
jointly put more flexibility
into the entire system.
As you probably know,
the United States
is the only
industrialized country
without paid leave for
maternity, let alone paternity.
We need to change that.
And we have no childcare system.
The last time there
was a bill in Congress
for a childcare system was 1971,
and Nixon vetoed that bill.
And no bill has come
to Congress since then.
So Hillary Clinton now has a
plan for a childcare system.
But it's been 45 years
since Congress took up
the notion of a childcare
system for the country.
So there's work to do,
obviously in your own family,
in your workplace, and in
the society as a whole.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
AUDIENCE: I've
always put about 30%
on-- as the figure
for how much extra
our family spends that it
wouldn't if one parent stayed
home full time.
And that's for house
cleaning, take out,
guilt gifts for the kids.
Is that an accurate figure?
Have you got any stats on that?
MYRA STROBER: I don't
have stats on that.
But I think that as families
make decisions about
whether both parents
should work or not,
you don't want to make a
decision based on short run
factors.
So what some people
do is they say,
this is the salary
that the second earner
could earn in the workplace.
And here's what we have to pay
for all the factors you talked
about-- childcare, extra
cleaning, take out,
often an extra car.
OK.
So does it pay?
Is my salary or the other
person's salary high
enough to cover all those costs?
So I don't think
that's a good way
to think about this, because
this is not a short run issue.
This is a long term issue.
And if you take into account
the decrease in salary that's
going to take place when the
person who left the workforce
comes back, then over a lifetime
of-- well, not a lifetime,
but a work lifetime-- those
childcare costs and guilt
gifts-- I love that, guilt
gifts-- and extra cleaning
and whatever are
going to be minimal.
It's really an
economic investment
to pay for those
things in order to keep
a person in the workforce,
keep those skills current,
keep those networks
up, and get the income
from the second person.
And also it's not a good
idea to think about will
the second person's salary
cover these expenses?
Because really these
are family expenses.
And you don't want
to think about them
as having the second
earner needing
to cover those expenses.
Both people are responsible.
AUDIENCE: I have a
question around kind
of the lean in movement
and having women
who are going on maternity
leave coming back,
reporting in to me.
Everyone has different
experiences around it.
For me I read the book
at a very powerful time
when I had my first child.
And it kind of inspired me to
really come back and come back
full force.
But I have a lot of women
who when we talk about it,
they feel that there's
almost double pressure.
So I've had a
different experience.
I actually think
the lean in movement
and all the research has
been helpful in my career
on sticking with the workforce.
But there are people
that report to me
that say it's put too much
pressure on them as women.
I'm curious in your
research at Stanford
and your engagement
how you address it.
And I know it's not one
size fits all, right?
But ultimately, how do you
respond to women that feel,
god, there's so much
pressure to be amazing moms,
to be full throttle
into our career as well?
MYRA STROBER: So
I think the point
you make that no one
size fits all is the key.
And we have very interesting
discussions in my classes.
I teach a class at
the Stanford Business
School on work and family.
And 40% of the students are men.
And some of them have
had a fair amount
of work experience, because
they are back for what
used to be known at the business
school as the Sloan program.
Now it has some other
name-- MSX or something.
And so a lot of
those men are very
proud of the way in
which they helped women
to handle coming back
to work after pregnancy.
And so they talk
about what they did.
And invariably, some woman
will raise her hand and say,
that's not what I
want when I come back.
So your point that
different women
want different things--
one women will say,
when I come back I
want to be full force.
I don't want anybody to
change my travel schedule.
change my number of meetings.
I want to be there full force.
And others will say what
some of your reports say.
No, I can't handle
that right now.
I need to move over a
little bit, take away
some of my responsibilities,
and in a few years
I'd like to be
able to move back.
That's the key.
It used to be that the
so-called mommy track took away
responsibilities, but
then you were gone.
You were gone from the screen.
And when you said you
wanted to come back,
the answer was too bad for you.
You've missed the train.
You can't get on
that track anymore,
which is really a foolish way
to think about human resources.
You were out for a few
years, so now we're
never going to use
you full force again.
But the manager
really has to have
a conversation with the report
to find out what's desired.
And the second thing
about that is people
can change their mind.
So you have that conversation
before the woman-- or even
the man-- leaves for family
leave, and then they come back
and they have a
different perception.
I mean, so many
things can happen.
They might have a child
with special needs.
Well, they didn't anticipate
that when they told you
they want to come
back full force.
Or they might find that
their own health is not
as strong as they
thought it was going
to be for whatever reason.
So yes, it's good to have a
conversation before the person
goes out on leave.
See what they're thinking.
But then the real
key to conversation
when they are
ready to come back.
And I think lean in
is very important,
because it says try
to do your best.
I think Sheryl Sandberg's
main message is
don't leave before you leave.
That's critical.
Keep going full force
for as long as you can,
assuming your health is good.
But I think that leaning in
is only part of the story.
I think that you need to have
employers who meet you halfway.
Otherwise, I always
tell my students,
if you keep leaning in and
nobody is there to meet you,
you're just going to fall over.
So that doesn't do
anybody any good.
So yes, you need to work hard.
But employers need
to have policies
that meet people halfway.
I think that Deloitte has done
a really good job of trying
to figure out how to have
lots of different pads
after people leave the workforce
or come back part time.
And then as they are
ready to resume full tilt,
then they're
welcomed to do that.
I think that's really ideal.
SPEAKER 1: What is
a real world example
of a band of
acceptability agreement
a couple could have in
place in their relationship?
MYRA STROBER: Well, one aspect
of the band of acceptability
might have to do with how many
nights a week the family eats
dinner together.
So seven is one possibility.
But you might say,
look, it's fine
if one partner misses dinner
with the family one night
a week and a second partner
misses dinner with the family.
So now the family is going to
have dinner five nights a week.
Or maybe the couple
is going to go out
for dinner by themselves
one night a week,
so now the family eats
together four nights a week.
When children get older,
that may be impossible--
not because of the
parents' work schedule
but because of the
kids' sports schedules.
So then you might say,
OK, every Sunday morning
our family is going to have
a pancake breakfast together.
And nothing can
interfere with that.
So that would be a
band of acceptability.
Or you could have acceptability
rules about travel.
So how many nights a month is it
OK for one or the other partner
to be outside the city,
in some other city?
OK.
Is it fine five nights a week?
Four nights a week?
10 days a month?
Whatever your family
decides is right, then
if things begin to move toward
more and more nights away,
you can sit down and say to
one another, wait a minute.
Look.
This isn't what we
said we wanted to do.
Something has to change here.
So that would be an example.
SPEAKER 1: It's common
for working mothers
to be asked why
they have children
if their children will
spend most of their waking
hours with someone else.
How do you think about the
role of a working parent
and, in particular, how best
to measure your contribution
to your children if you can't
win on, quote unquote, "time?"
MYRA STROBER:
Although you may be
away for many of the child's
waking hours, you as a parent
are going to be
right there for other
of those working--
of the child's hours.
Certainly on the
weekends, in the evening,
in the early morning.
And I think parents
have a tremendous effect
on their children even if
their children are in childcare
or if they're raised
by a third parent
like a grandparent or a nanny.
One of the interesting
ways to think about this
is when a child is cared for
not only by his or her parents
but also by another person,
and the other person
has a different
accent, the child
picks up the parents' accent.
So over hundreds of years,
English royal children
were raised by people who
didn't necessarily have
the upper class English accent.
And somehow or
other, those children
figure out which accent
they're supposed to imitate.
And I think that's true
for not just language.
I think children know very
early who their parents are
and the kind of love that
they get from those parents
hopefully.
And there is a bond that isn't
created by a nanny or childcare
worker or even a grandparent.
There's a different kind
of love with a grandparent.
So I think there's
plenty of hours
in the week for parents to
interact with their kids
to show them they love them.
And I'm just amazed all
the time by my students
and former students who talk
about ways in which they have
created to interact
with their children
even when they're traveling.
So now we have Skype.
I mean that's a phenomenal way
to be involved with your kids.
Before that we had
phone conversations.
So I just think
that children know
who their parents are
and know the kind of love
that they get from
those parents.
And you know, also
students tell me
that when they can't be at
their child's ballet recital,
they have somebody
there who videotapes it.
And then they sit with the
child and watch the videotape.
And they say that's
even better than having
been in the audience, because
now we can stop the tape.
We can talk about what the
child was doing and feeling.
So I think with technology and
with a little bit of thinking
about this, parents can have
very fruitful relationships
with their children even
if they're working hard.
AUDIENCE: My question is
about the body of work
available on this subject.
How much research is
available with children
being the subjects?
MYRA STROBER: There's
a tremendous amount
of research available.
My daughter-in-law,
Joanna Strober,
and a co-author
Sharon Meers have
a book called "Getting to
50/50," which was published,
I think, 2009 maybe.
And that has a review of the
research up to that time.
For beyond that really you
can go onto the internet
and find a tremendous
amount of research.
If you want to, Google
Scholar is terrific on this
to find the serious journal
articles but also government
publications.
There's just an enormous
amount of stuff out there.
Too much.
It's hard to sift through it.
AUDIENCE: This kind of
gray area where men--
they're not leaning out.
They're not the
primary caregiver,
but they are potentially
taking a little bit of a valley
in their career to
support potentially
a woman, their partner,
who's really full force.
It could be a new job.
It could be a move.
And just the way-- is
our society evolved
enough to accept it?
And it comes from
a personal example.
I've moved from New York
for this Google position.
It's a fairly big job.
My husband's kind of leaning
in and supporting me.
And it's interesting.
He shares with me--
he's still working.
He's running his business, but
it's not at the New York base.
And a lot of
parents and school--
he does more of the drop
offs-- kind of always
hint to him, like, hey, when
are you going to get back in?
When are you-- and
he's like, I'm in.
I'm just not in at 120% like
where Lena is right now,
because Google's new.
It's intense.
It's interesting-- this
gray area that maybe people
don't want to talk about.
And I'm curious if you see
this, when the men are kind
of supporting their
wives, but then society
thinks that they've
completely leaned out.
I don't know.
Just curious.
MYRA STROBER: I think it's
really tough for men who are
trying to make these changes.
Because they do get
those kinds of comments.
And they have to be not
only strong in terms
of their career, they have
to be strong in facing
all these other--
usually mothers-- who
have all these words about
what they should and shouldn't
be doing.
And I've often thought
it would be fun
to have a class for men
who are, as you say,
leaning in to support
their wives to give them
some comments that they
might offer in return
for these negative
comments about when are you
going to get back in and so on.
I just think that whenever
you are a pioneer,
you have to face these societal
norms that haven't changed yet.
And in my book "Sharing
the Work," you know,
I was a pioneer.
I was the first woman at the
Stanford Business School.
And the book is filled with
these kinds of discussions
about what I had to face.
Now the pioneers are
people like your husband
who are really bucking
the trends and are saying,
no, my wife has gotten
a great job at Google.
And I'm going to support her.
And she's going all the way.
And I'm still
staying in, but I'm
doing more childcare than I
might have done otherwise.
And I think you
have to be a pioneer
and you have to be strong.
SPEAKER 1: Can you
talk about challenges
taking care of aging parents and
family members and any nuances
to what you've
covered with regard
to partnering balance on this
topic-- sorry-- with regard
to partnering slash
balance on this topic
versus childcare balance?
MYRA STROBER: That's a
really important question.
I didn't have a section on elder
care in my work family course
until maybe seven
or eight years ago
when one of the men in my class
did a paper on elder care.
And at the bottom of
his paper, he said,
I think this topic
should be in the class.
And I thought to myself,
yes, it really should.
And so since that time we do
have the topic in the class.
And in many ways,
elder care is more
challenging than childcare.
I mean, even though
children may be rebellious,
basically the parents
are in charge.
The parents make the
decisions and try
to get the children to go along.
That's not true with elder care.
Adult children are not in
charge of their parents.
Adult children have to wait for
their parents to make decisions
that they can support.
They can try to influence them,
but the parents are in charge.
The other thing is
that children grow up.
So childcare is only
for a few years,
and then they become
teenagers, which
is a whole different story.
But you know, then they
stop being teenagers
and they grow up more.
With elder care you don't
know how long your parent
is going to need care.
You don't know
whether the situation
is going to get better
or more likely worse.
It's much less predictable.
They often don't live in the
same city where you live.
And the statistics seem
to show that more days are
lost from work by adults doing
elder care than childcare.
Because childcare
is predictable.
So you can line up help.
But elder care, particularly if
you have to go to another state
to take care of your
parent, is not predictable.
And I think elder care
is still not talked
about much in the workplace.
A lot of people don't
want their manager
to know that they're involved
in elder care, because they're
spending a lot of time
at work doing this.
And so I believe
this is the topic
for the future with regard
to work family balance.
And if there's an
emergency with your parent,
there is no balance.
None at all.
150% of your time and
effort is involved
in trying to deal
with this emergency.
And then you have to make
all the other arrangements,
especially if you're in the
so-called sandwich generation,
where you not only
have elder parents
but you have young children.
So then you're really
running from one to the other
to try to get the
balance that you need.
Interestingly, more
and more studies
show that men are more
involved in elder care.
So it used to be when
wives were at home and not
in the workplace that
they did the elder
care, not only for
their parents but also
for their husband's parents.
But that's not so true anymore.
So more and more men are doing
the care for their own parents
and really stepping up to that.
So, again, that's a whole
new sort of pioneering.
SPEAKER 1: Can you
give any guidance
on the proper timing
and method to start
speaking with your manager
about your decision
to start family planning?
MYRA STROBER: So
I think this idea
of when you should talk to your
manager also is very specific.
The specifics of the situation
are really important.
If you know that your manager
is going to be helpful
and isn't going to say to
you something like, oh god,
why did you go and do that?
You could have had
a great career.
Then you might want to talk
to your manager early on.
If you think your manager is
not going to be supportive,
you might want to wait a little
bit more before you talk.
But pregnancy has a way,
particularly for women,
of showing.
So your manager's going to find
out at some point or other.
And it's probably better
if you talk to your manager
before he or she can see
that you're pregnant.
And so I think
the best example I
know is a former
student of mine who
was in strategic planning
at a tech company.
This was years ago.
And she went into her
manager early on and said,
this is the plan.
This is the strategic plan for
my pregnancy and childbirth.
So here is a flow chart.
And here's what I'm going to be
doing for the next six months.
And then I'm going to
take some time off,
and I'm going to check in
at each of these points.
And then after six months,
I'm coming back full time.
And she said, you
can't find anybody
to do this job better than I
can given this strategic plan I
just gave you.
And he sort of said, bless you.
So you know, if you
say what you want
and how you're going to do
it, and you're confident--
and, of course, everybody
has to understand
that things might not
quite work out that way,
depending on what happens.
But you can say with
90% confidence perhaps
that this is what
is going to happen.
Here's what we're going to do.
AUDIENCE: I was
wondering if you could
share some of your
suggestions for how
to make that dip in a
career for a couple, two
young professionals
with, let's say,
relatively successful careers.
When I took your
class, I remember
you talked about one
suggestion, which
was hiring a night nanny even
though it's quite expensive.
But there's actually
quite a lot of benefit
of getting a good night's
sleep for both partners
and then having a
more productive day
and the psychological.
So I was hoping to get a
refresher on things like that.
MYRA STROBER: Well, of course,
if you have a lot of money,
then there are lots of
solutions like a night nanny.
If you are not in such a
great financial situation,
then, of course,
you're more limited.
And you have to
be more creative.
When I see graduate students at
Stanford who, by definition, do
not have a lot of money--
well, unless their parents have
a tremendous amount of money.
But they don't have
a lot of money.
They use a co-op method.
So when they want
to go out to a movie
or they want to go
out for dinner or date
night or something--
they probably
won't go out for a movie--
but out for dinner,
just the two of them.
Instead of hiring
a babysitter, which
can cost more than the
dinner, they will trade off.
So they'll say, you
know, tonight we're
going to go out for dinner.
You watch both your
children and mine.
And then tomorrow night you
go, and I'll watch yours.
I think there's lots
of ways of cooperating
with other people who also have
young children that work out
very well.
Even would you take my
child for the afternoon
so I can get a nap-- if your
child is not napping anymore.
Otherwise try to nap
when the child naps.
That's always a good thing.
But I think your
question is wonderful,
because it shows you that
you have to think creatively
about how to do this.
It was easier in
the old days where
you had lots of family
living around you,
and you could just
drop your kid off
for a few hours with
somebody in your family.
Now you have to arrange
those kinds of new family
arrangements with people who
are actually friends by choice
rather than family members.
But truly if you have a
lot of money-- I mean,
I know people who hire
more than one nanny.
Some nanny comes
from 8:00 to 6:00.
Another nanny comes
from 5:00 to 9:00.
And then if the child is
a newborn and not sleeping
through the night, they
might hire a night nurse.
So all of those things are
possible for a very few people.
SPEAKER 1: So this is sort
of adding on to the co-op
question, but how
important is it
to have a network
of women at your job
once you come back that
are sort of experiencing
the same experiences as you are?
MYRA STROBER:
Well, I don't think
it's necessarily necessary
to have it at your job.
Some women prefer to have
a network of women doing
the same thing they're
doing but at other companies
so that they can be 100%
frank about what's going on
and not worry that somebody
is at their own workplace.
Other people like to have a
network at their workplace.
But no matter how you
slice it, a network is key.
I know when I was
raising my kids,
there were very few
professional women.
And my network consisted of
my kids' friends' mothers
at their nursery school.
So they weren't
professional women at all.
But they were so helpful
to me in so many ways.
If my babysitter couldn't
come because she had a family
emergency, I would
call one of them.
And they would take my children
home with them at lunch time.
You can't do this
just by yourself.
And, of course,
the luckiest thing
is if you can get your parents
to move near where you are.
Or you move back.
I mean, I had a student
who-- she and her husband
moved back to Shanghai,
because that's
where their parents were.
And they could not imagine
doing this kind of thing
without their parents' help.
So you know, the
geographic location
had nothing to do with
their two careers.
It had to do with where
their parents were.
SPEAKER 1: Thank you so much.
MYRA STROBER: You're welcome.
[APPLAUSE]